i mean it was an escalation because you
had not just um
you know one person trump or his
supporters
being ghosted or d platform but you had
16 million parlor users or whatever is
99.9
of whom never did anything wrong you
know and that was a diminishment of
their free speech rights um
it was also i think uh unjustified
uh if if the justification for that
was that parlor was used in the planning
of the events of january 6. it was
clearly a scapegoating because
um we now have fbi charging documents
have come out they found
226 cases the social networking site
that was used
10x more than all the others was facing
you know parlor was used
one tenth of the amount that facebook
was but parlor was
you know was sort of an easy and easy
target to sort of scapegoat for that
can you talk a little bit about how you
think that cartel works because you've
written a little bit about this
like when trump got taken out after
january 6 when they took him off spotify
and pinterest and twitter and youtube
you know it wasn't even the ones where
he was it's like okay now he can't
listen to music anymore either like
we're just gonna take him out of
everything
that that they operate sort of as a
cartel it's like they just wait for the
first mover
and then everybody sort of in a minute
does the exact same thing
well so jack dorsey actually explained
it um he wrote a tweet storm in which he
needed felt the need to defend the their
action to permanently
uh de-platform uh well you had a funny
you had a funny comment on what he said
because it's like he does these things
and then he suddenly feels very
emotional about what he's done and then
he
opens up about everything they make
these knee-jerk decisions that there's
like a violent reaction to it and then
because they don't they have a blind
spot with respect to their you know
their partisan biases and then they
realize oh wait a second we just did
something that
is a big deal and then he comes out and
gets very introspective and tries to
explain it
um at least he tries to explain it that
makes jack my my favorite oligarch
but what what he said is that when we
twitter decided to ban
trump um we didn't think it was that big
a deal
because there were other places he could
go to basically get his free speech
right and then all these other companies
did the same thing
um and and he's right if if only one
company
were to you know de-platform you it
might not be that big a deal but when
all of them are doing it at the same
time
they're acting as effectively a speech
cartel now
what what jack said is that they that
all of us
you know didn't collude to make these
decisions but we emboldened each other
that was his word is emboldened
it sounds a lot to to me what we would
call
signaling an anti-trust law where you
have a bunch of companies
that normally compete with each other
and therefore
are trying to make different decisions
not not all trying to get to the same
decision
to try and compete with each other but
signaling occurs when one company does
something and then you know all the
other companies follow suit
and that's basically what's happening
is that um is that with each incremental
company
that decides to to ban trump or whoever
the pressure builds
on all the rest of them to do the same
thing otherwise they'll be subject to
you know letter writing campaigns and
boy and all that kind of stuff
and so you know whether they're actively
colluding or not or whether it's merely
just a signaling
you have the same effect which is a
cartel
so would you break them up i mean would
you use the force of government
to to break up some of these companies
at this point i would seriously look at
it because i think they are too powerful
but i don't think it's going to solve
the speech problem for this reason
imagine that google is busted up into
you know we have kind of google search
and then youtube becomes its own
property
and you know maybe there's like a third
division for
enterprise well i mean youtube's the one
that that we we sort of care about
it's we're not going to divide that
property up it's still going to be run
it'll just have a different cap table
it's going to have the same ship the
same executives
they all drink from the same sort of
monocultural fountain they all have the
same
ideological commitments and biases
they're subject to
most of the same pressures so i don't
know
that if you effectively increase the
size of the speech cartel
from five members to ten members i don't
know that that by itself does anything
i think what we need i'm and i'm not
expecting to get this
from congress anytime soon is um some
sort of common carrier
obligations imposed on these big tech
monopolies
uh this is a proposal that came from
richard epstein's professor
at the universicago basically what he
says
is look if you're a gigantic monopoly or
a utility you can't deny
a service to somebody based on their
creed
you know that that's the
non-discrimination rule that we need
uh imagine if um you know like a common
carrier would be
something like a railroad you know where
it's it's a it's a natural monopoly uh
imagine if in the days of the lincoln
douglas debates
and you know they got around the country
by train imagine if
i don't know some oligarch cornelius
vanderbilt or something said you know
mr lincoln i don't i don't like your
your point of view in this debate i'm
going to deny you
service i don't want you to be able to
express your views well there's no way
that we would have let
that happen we wouldn't let body we
wouldn't let
monopolies be that powerful where they
can deny service
to a essential facilities to people
based on their creed
and that basically is the the
legislative fix here i think
more than doing something like repealing
section 230 which i think would hurt a
lot of small innovators right um
so so yeah but look you know i'm not
expecting to get that in the next two
years or even four years so
i'm guessing generally speaking though
you'd rather have technological
solutions to this than governmental
solutions
i i would but um but i don't know that
we're gonna get a technological solution
because
i do think that you know monopolies are
are real i mean
part of what i do as an investor is
trying to invest in the next set of
monopolies
and um you know
and you know that's what peter peter's
whole book uh zero to one is about is
there's there's two kinds of companies
right there
right there michelle yeah i mean there's
two kinds of companies right there's
monopolies and commodities you want to
be a monopoly well monopolies have
incredible market power
um i think it was it was fine
when those monopolies were lawfully
gained and weren't trying to use their
power
to put their thumb on the scale of
american democracy um
you know and and it wasn't that long ago
that these big tech companies
you know uh would state their
their commitment to neutrality i mean
mark zuckerberg gave i think a very good
speech
just a few years ago in 2018
in which he said that he said social
networks were
were the fifth estate you know the the
the traditional media historically was
the fourth estate
i don't know i think one through three
were like they go back to europe or
something like the nobility and the
peasants the people yeah the people yeah
yeah
anyway the fourth estate is traditional
media what zuckerberg said is that
social networks were the fifth estate
and that they posed a threat to the
people in power just like the
the fourth estate did and therefore
needed to be protected
and i think he's right about that
and the the sad thing is that he
has felt the need to kind of move off
that position
um and and engage in this sort of
censorship he's he's yeah when you see
these guys have to
go in front of congress you know when
you see jack or zuckerberg
i don't know if you know them personally
you know probably at least somewhere in
the circles or somewhat close but when
you see them have to
you know basically be arguing with
people who have so little understanding
of what the real issues are or any of
that stuff does it just
like drive you crazy to see it
it's a little painful you know because
the the people doing the
the questioning by and large don't don't
have the
knowledge to or ability to kind of
interrogate
the these ceos the way the way that they
should but
some of them do you know there have been
some interesting moments where the ceos
get
questioned and sort of dressed down i
mean there's a lot of like
theater it's very performative there's a
lot of grandstanding i mean
i don't really know how much progress
gets made in these in these hearings but
the point of it i think is valid which
is you have these
a handful of tech oligarchs who now
control
the public square and they've
appropriated
to themselves a vast power to decide
who has access and which views have
access and
which views they're going to silence and
censor and basically
ghost and you know and no one elected
them to have that power
and i think we should be rightly
concerned about that and i think we
should
question them about how they are
wielding that power
how much of an escalation do you think
it was when parlor
got nuked by amazon because that was
completely different taking away servers
than
you know taking away speech of an
individual person
yeah i mean it was an escalation because
you had not just
um you know one person trump or his
supporters
being ghosted or d platform but you had
16 million parlor users or whatever is
99.9
of whom never did anything wrong you
know and that was a diminishment of
their free speech rights
um it was also i think uh unjustified
uh if the justification for that
was that parlor was used in the planning
of the events of january 6 it was
clearly a scapegoating because
um we now have fbi charging documents
have come out they found
226 cases the social networking site
that was used
10x more than all the others was facing
you know parlor was used
one tenth of the amount that facebook
was but parlor was
you know was sort of an easy and easy
target to sort of scapegoat for that
is that purely because of sort of the
cartel mindset
that you were discussing before like
there's certain there's you know however
many people or companies are involved in
the cartel and here's just this new guy
so it's like
well they are competition there are 21
million people over there may as well
just take them out right
yeah i mean it's yeah i think they're an
easy target
um i think facebook clearly was eager to
deflect blame
onto parlor there was actually a pretty
good article in the washington post
uh about that um you know calling
facebook out on that
um pointing to the fact that they had a
lot more of this problematic content
than
than parlor did uh but yeah i mean it's
an easy way for these big tech companies
to show that they're doing something
uh to control you know disinformation or
whatever that the powers that be now you
know are concerned about and
again i think this all goes back to the
fact that
uh these the big tech companies are very
worried about getting broken up right
now they don't want to get busted up and
so they're looking at curry favor
with you know the current administration
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about tech
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell